in this video we're going to see how to
load and fine-tune a pre-trained model
it's very quick and if you've watched
our pipeline videos which i'll link
below the process is very similar
this time though we're going to be using
transfer learning and doing some
training ourselves rather than just
loading a model and using it as is
so to learn more about transfer learning
head to the what is transfer learning
video and we'll link that below as well
but for now let's look at this code to
start we pick which model we want to
start with in this case we're going to
use the famous the original bert as our
the foundation for our training today
but what is this monstrosity line this
tf auto model for sequence
classification what does that mean
well the tf stands for tensorflow and
the rest means take a language model and
stick a sequence classification head
onto it if it doesn't have one already
so this line of code loads bert which is
a general purpose language model it
loads at weights architecture and all
and then adds a new sequence
classification head onto it with
randomly initialized weights
so this method needs to know two things
firstly it needs to know the name of the
model you want it to load the
architecture and weights for
and secondly it needs to know how many
classes your problem has because that
will determine the size the number of
neurons in the output head
so if you want to follow along with the
data from our data sets videos which
i'll link below then you'll have two
classes positive and negative and thus
num labels equals two
but what about this compile line
well if you're familiar with keras
you've probably seen this already but if
not this is one of the core methods in
keras that you're going to see again and
again you always need to compile your
model before you train it and compile
needs to know two things
firstly it needs to know the loss
function which is what you're trying to
optimize
so here we import the sparse categorical
cross entropy loss function
so that's a mouthful but it's the
standard loss function for any neural
network that's doing a classification
task
it basically encourages the network to
output large values for the right class
and low values for the wrong classes
note that you can specify the loss
function as a string like we did with
the optimizer but there's there's a risk
there there's a very common trap people
fall into which is that by default this
loss assumes the output is probabilities
after a soft max layer but what our
model has actually output is the values
before the softmax
often called the logits sometimes logits
no one's quite sure how to pronounce
that one but you you've probably seen
these before in the video about
pipelines
so if you get this wrong your model
won't train and it'll be very annoying
to figure out why
in future videos we're going to see how
to use the model's internal loss
computations so that you don't have to
specify the loss yourself and you don't
have to worry about these details but
for now remember to set from logits to
true
the second thing compile needs to know
is the optimizer you want in our case we
use adam which is sort of the standard
optimizer for deep learning these days
the one thing you might want to change
is the learning rate and to do that
we'll need to import the actual
optimizer rather than just calling it by
string but we'll talk about that in
another video which i'll link below for
now let's just try training the model
well so how do you train the model again
if you've used keras before this is all
going to be very familiar to you but if
not let's very quickly look at what
we're doing here
fit is pretty much the central method
for keras models it tells the model to
train on the data we're passing in
so here we pass the data sets we made in
the previous section the data set
contains both our inputs and our labels
so we don't need to specify separate
labels when we're calling fit
then we do the same thing with the
validation data and then we can if we
want we can specify details like the
number of epochs for training or there
are some other arguments you can pass to
fit but you in the end you just
pass all of this to model fit and you
let it run if everything works out you
should see a little training bar
progressing along as your loss goes down
and that's it while that's running you
you know you can call your boss and tell
them you're a senior nlp machine
learning engineer now and you're going
to want a salary review next quarter
this these few lines of code are really
all it takes to apply the power of a
massive pre-trained language problem a
massive pre-trade language model excuse
me to your nlp problem
but could we do better than this i mean
we certainly could uh with a few more
advanced keras features like a tuned
scheduled learning rate we can get an
even lower loss at an even more accurate
more useful model
and what do we do with our model after
we train it so all of this is going to
be covered in the videos that are coming
up so stay tuned